io ho fatto un regalo che c'è quasi la
guarda guarda da casa
che bello il black friday veramente
grazie si è molto gentile
complice forse non ne prendi dove
vagamente anche tracce si simile
quelli sono i regali quelli brutti che
devi accettare lo stesso e far finta che
ti piacciono cretino bene a tutti i
ragazzi muniti questo modo sono farisei
agis entrati con il mio pietro che mi ha
fatto un bel regalo grazie per la7 se
proprio gentile siamo rimasti
nell'ultimo episodio che c'era la torre
pietro già a lui è già finita la sala
dove ha già l'ultimo episodio della
serie l'utilità di mettere delle torce
di giorno sono pietro la sa però va bene
stiamo giocando lo stesso gioco abbiamo
lo stesso quoziente intellettivo no
perché se non usa mezzi le scale quelle
già fatte allora però va bene non fare
che schifo che schifo che schifo alla
montagna amica e tu hai scritto mica
pietro sulla montagna non ho capito
secondo me guarda che sto dungeon qua
avrà sotto nella montagna dentro
incavato un'apertura gigante un'arena un
qualcosa poi scopre che in realtà non
c'è niente c'è uno sgabuzzino stupido
musica epica mentre controlliamo tana
non questa contro sopra vedi che c'è la
scala di sotto lo sapevo lo sapevo
potremmo prima sopra di una casa sopra
aspetta aspetta che arrivo e vedo il
cretino non sei capace faccio io prima
prima io prima io e sempre comunque
migliore del tuo regalo
[Risate]
abbiamo saputo che figo guardali che
panorama mamma mi ha neanche le alpi
madonna madonna se madonna se cadevo
madonna se te lo giuro venivo lì a
prenderti a calci neri qui andiamo
andiamo prima le donne ma perché non ti
ammazzi nel fuoco perché non accennino
quando serve permesso raga faceva
vediamo brutta sento dei rumori brutti
tipo quello che fa pietro la mattina
smettila di sculacciarmi
permesso aiuto aiuto
aspetta aspetta che abbiamo visto cose
ci sono due dai due espone uno e due
bene ammazzatelo ammazzato così vi amo
abbiamo sì grazie
siete fantastici amici fanno magrassi
mockus marwan allora allora
ristabiliamo la gerarchia questo è mio
questo è mio cuore questo mio
c'era qualcuno in questa serie oltre
meno ammazzatelo pietro vi prego
passatelo che non è bello quando non c'è
lui madonna cosa sto vedendo faccio io
eccola dove arrivavano vado a fuoco sono
quasi morto pietro faccio io
quanta gente sono porta verso la porta
ma magari se vai avanti
ok dovrei averli fatti fuori da una
scala all'altra ci ha fatto fuori
un'intera spada per fare questa roba
cioè non 16
quanti sono impossibile dare definiti
non credo viene cioè era l'ultimo quello
mi sai perché avevo fatto
madonna è possibile fuori 20 mila
persone l'ultimo ma ucciso porca vacca
ma che difficoltà hai messo tra l'altro
al prossimo ci mancava perché noi le
cose normali non le sappiamo fare vero
pietro assolutamente no amica attuale
robben veloce li ottieni mi sento rumori
strani vanno troppo ma quanti sono e
basta
madonna non è possibile la franchigia
facciamo ci affacciamo si spacca yo yo
riuscito madonna quanti sono a chiamo lo
scheletro bareilles spacca spacca che
però paga e lo so abbiamo tutti lo
stesso non ce la fanno romano baratri
all'oratorio bravissimo ad attori siamo
in una situazione veramente drastica
pietro primo incarico
ok ci sono anch'io diamo un'occhiata ai
aiuto lancia una bomba fa qualcosa
l'uomo
l'ultimo no no io ci sono riuscito ti
spacchi 200 specie un kg per cercare la
donna per morto lo zombie villaggio in
tutto questo bene può arrivare fino a
qua è stato un pardo ma ce l'abbiamo
fatta
stiamo migliorando ma cos'è sto d'angio
mai gigante ma non pensavo così grosso
in realtà altro carena all'inizio io li
odio gli scheletri te lo giuro
c'è una cesta in una gabbia c'e la
cessione una gabbia occhio chiamo fanno
malissimo sinisi parco e tu e spacchi
che ha rotto
ok fatta fatta oddio come si entra qua
non puoi ha effettivamente abbiamo
indicato di questa cosa non solo per
anche le bare scusami dove libertà con
la quale spada è cosa dici ma cosa dici
che cosa vuole questo
allora io tieniti dopo harry prima
perché tanto in tanto dura un sacco che
questa spada sharpless 5 gr co2 smart2
ben o fa troppo cosa vuol dire breaking
hicks a breaking abbia finito all
d'angelo quindi premio era la spada al
di di gesù bene intensi ma festa che è
direi che è utile se però godley sword
si chiama la spada di dio si chiama
veramente così dei ragazzi abbiamo
esplorato il dungeon è stato e notte
però è occhio pietro quest'anno in casa
del corso a prato 36 notte non è che
sono un veggente c'è uno scheletro beh
vabbè scusa lo implora scusa o il plauso
vista roba implode la gente pietro vieni
qua no no no direi di andare a dormire
facciamo questa cosa andiamo a dormire e
domani al risveglio andremo alla ricerca
di nuovi dungeon perché credo che tutti
i dungeon abbiano una ricompensa per
quanto siano difficili per carità però
alto se si pensa che prima se non
avevamo la spada quella che tu adesso ma
perché questa persona il b è nata tra
miliardo di spermatozoi hai vinto tu
porca vacca andiamo a cercare nato
langiano sono sparsi lange un tipo
questo credo per la mappa però non ho
idea di dove sei
io non ti veniamo alla cieca andiamo la
ceca quando andiamo in giro e tradizione
e cantare una canzone passamontagna e
qua sono generate automaticamente che
faccio corpo bella mi sembra il signore
degli anelli quando attraverso il passo
del
vi ricordo che si chiama il passo il
passo di il posto di qualcuno a quello
delle montagne va bene siamo la panda
più vulcanica gli scarafaggi e di
calamità veniamo giù per la discarica e
pietro dentro la foresta sparirà dove
sei finito qua carapax casca scarafaggi
skalka scarafaggi skanska eccoti ti ho
visto ti ho visto giù e io sono sopra un
albero madonna quanto quanto bella
questa isola mamma mia
c'è un cane c'era un cane e va bene ma
che ne so cani campagno far farne pausa
merenda guarda c'è una pecora nera lì e
poi c'è anche questo animale grazioso
area c so se si guarda guarda te umani
card c'è un main kart di un carrello
della spesa modo lo vedi è vero che non
vedi e vero e non lo vedono vedere cos'è
questa roba qua
aspetta aspetta ciao amici ciao di 16 e
11 anni mi spingo yo yo vice evan dando
ai a anch'io bene è stato è stato
veramente bello tipo gardaland
c'è gente c'è gente ragazze il ku kux
klan il ku kux klan con i piccoli di
ferro è un casino qua
lo accuserà questo rumore brutto e
scoraggiato sentito rumore bruttissimo
ma tua madre ti ha fatto mera era sobria
quando ti ha fatto che problemi hai c'è
un clip e va bene quanta gente così
brutta
ma io la spada della madonna aia per un
pò lo spoiler robot squander non per
stoner perfetto o tutto metti torce
fatto fatto ok c'è un ragno velenoso
occhio ucciso ma poi hanno fatto sono
forte questa spada incredibile meno male
perché costa difficoltà qua non faremo
un passo
andiamo andiamo andiamo che i miei non
ha bisogno
se andiamo ancora proprio in basso la
vedro che la troviamo in un attimo
faccio tutto io tu la stata fortissima
ho capito tanto c'è un altro stoner con
attenzione qui sotto anche andato faccio
io facevo end ha penato ahi ahi ahi ahi
ahi morte morte morte morto stai
tranquillo c'è pieno di jolo qua il film
possa ucciderti no volevo alleviare le
tue sofferenze
so benissimo così grazie
ok massacro c'è una cassino vista l'ho
vista con la coda dell'occhio bene siamo
arrivati no cosa sto vedendo non ha
natura la mamma mia oh
un file michael e non fai lavoro di
squadra ti giuro non l'avevo visto sto
principi socialista la va a destra ma
non pensavo fosse così allora quasi fa
il salto della fede pietro 6 prima tu
però vado vado se funziona vieni
[Musica]
io ho fatto niente non ho fatto niente
c'è un ragno quasi stato è stato ragno
il ragno che ha ucciso il ragno aragno
ha fatto la cosa che doveva fare un
nemico ragno c'era il diamante le chiama
amaco c'è una cesta 3 2 1 aprile mentre
tutti i picchi non c'era niente che
sfiga per te lo giuro non c'è nulla era
vuota l'immagine non c'era era vuota era
ghiottissima poi andiamo avanti e bravo
ma è quello il metodo venduto foglio
scusa qual è il mezzo che 6 19 st il
caffè questo evans a me lo cediamo rese
da sottoporre in the lava eccoli ma
dietro trovato degli amanti che tu non
avevi visto quando vieni fighter no no
no no no è il fratino è il è entrati o
ei ai ahia ahia
dietro l'acqua pietro ami se io avessi
se tu stai andando a fuoco io avessi
dell'acqua io la berrei ed è quello che
stai facendo tu
direi che abbiamo tutto a questo punto
abbiamo preso tutti gli amanti io ne ho
tratto non so continua in avrei 5
andiamo cosa stai facendo cosa era
comoda il giorno grazie a dio meno male
che azzecchiamo sempre riuscite giuste e
veramente va bene allora facciamo uscire
un attimo rifocilliamo c un secco che
questa parola non la usano mente di
tutta la mia vita in spiaggia che voglio
vedere come e basta poi torniamo a casa
ci stai bene allora i nostri
avventurieri
direi che possono fermarsi qua per il
semplice fatto che abbiamo fatto due
dungeon e c'è questo deserto immenso da
esplorare sicuramente nasconderà altri
dungeon molto più nefasti di quello di
quelli che abbiamo fatto bene cosa ne
nefasti ok e quindi ragazzi ricercatori
del deserto
così sta roba così visto aspettando poi
è un villaggio nei desideri estremi
l'agile deserto a quest'età minimo ma
che figata
non è un dungeon per un villaggio nel
deserto pre bellissimo ragazzi noi
concludiamo qua e probabilmente ci sarà
il dungeon nascosta da qualche parte nel
frattempo andiamo a fare
grazie nel frattempo andiamo a farci
conoscere
su questo bel tramonto dai villager qua
presenti nel deserto noi concordiamo
episodi ragazzi come descrizione in
attesa del lancio misterioso che
arriverà il prossimo episodio ci vediamo
da ragazzi non trovo il telecomando
eccolo da ragazzi
[Musica]